so this is a story that I've been
meaning to get to all week and we've run
out of time but I can't let this go
without a comment this is a story from
the New York Times op-ed page jogging
has always excluded black people
obviously this is coming in response to
the killing of Ahmad R burry and you
have one narrative which is saying he
was out for a jog and was hunted down by
krypto Klansmen and it was a lynching
then there's there people on the other
side who were now saying well he was
snooping around different houses
sometimes at night and he might have
been a burglar and whatever I'm not
talking about the armory killing here
and neither really is this this article
that's not really what it's about it's
about how jogging has excluded black
people born in lily-white Oregon it's a
sport that long claimed to be for
everyone even as african-american
joggers have been persistently subject
to harassment and worse free easy
relaxing that's how jogging was marketed
in the late 60s when the idea of heading
out on a regular run was unfamiliar to
most Americans unlike other physical
fitness programs that require heavy
expensive gear jogging was accessible to
all boosters claimed but history shows
how untrue that is and how long the
sport of running has maintained this
fiction it's untrue
they don't under 15 pleased as I have
never done in my entire life I think is
not available to everybody running has
been a pastime marketed primarily to
white people ever since the jogging
craze was born in in Oregon and the
sixties black people have not only been
excluded from the sport one survey by
running USA found under 10 percent of
frequent Wanderers identify as African
American how do you identify as African
amazed that like Rachel Dolezal you did
it's not that they are African American
they identify as it they've also been
relentlessly depicted as a threat to
legitimate white joggers so the fact the
New York Times is saying that because
most joggers are white that is evidence
that black people are being
systematically kept from jogging by whom
I have no idea ooh what jogging
Commission is
against the black people I don't think
one exists it couldn't possibly be the
case according to the New York Times
that more white people want a jog than
black people that some black people just
don't want a jog I don't want a jog I'm
never going to go jogging I would never
choose to go jogging but that choice
that's illegitimate this is the the
working of so much of the left's logic
is if something is not happening if if
what they want to be happening is not
happening that has to be evidence of
some new various sort of discrimination
it could never just be the result of
free choice the most apparently
egalitarian exercise of all running is
anything but especially when it comes to
race bla bla bla
this was written by natalia Millman pet
Sorella it was an assistant professor of
history at the new school and working on
a book on Fitness culture in the United
States so the new school is a little bit
of a hippie dippie school this is she's
a history professor something tells me
it's a little bit more and that study
this kind of realm if she's writing a
book on anjaan it seems a little bit
more like that critical studies kind of
stuff my main takeaway from this article
we've run out of problems in the United
States we don't have any problems people
always want to complain about something
it's just natural especially in a
decadent culture we've now run out of
things to complain about and so people
are complaining about jogging you know
there's this this system on the right or
on the left rather where they want to
see all sorts of nefarious bigots and
Klansmen and and misogynists and ever
everywhere every there are Nazis hiding
in every corner if you're on the left
not backed up by statistics that not
even close but that's to just imagine
these these phantom Nazis hiding
everywhere and they've now they've now
even taken this phantom oppression this
phantom discrimination this phantom
bigotry and madness even into the sport
of jogging guess we I guess we should be
pleased that we have so few problems in
America
and now I like apparently all of the
oppressed peoples of the world will
continue not to go for a job
[Music]
you
[Music]